it's easy to be taken in by Destiny's
gorgeous shell a slick and striking
rapper that surrounds the hollow and
unimaginative game languishing inside of
it make no mistake
Destiny's mechanical basics are for the
most part superb interacting with this
multiplayer only shooter is a delight
the gutsy shooting the fluid movement
the intuitive menus the smooth frame
rate all of these elements make for a
fantastic foundation for building a
great dynamic multiplayer shooter upon
the disappointment of destiny is how it
puts that solid foundation to use the
game is built upon soulless repetition
of unimaginative ideas take for instance
the story missions and strike missions
which have you taking two destinies
broad and beautiful settings with a
friend or two at your side by and large
every mission task is built upon the
same idea wait for your robotic
companion which is voiced by a Game of
Thrones actor Peter Dinklage to hack
into something usually a door then you
shoot a bunch of cool-looking aliens and
possibly a predictable bullet sponge
boss that absorbs five minutes worth of
gunfire before it falls then dinklebot
tells you he's finished coincidentally
right after you've finished killing the
last enemy and you answer the next
beautiful area to do it all again
different doors possibly different
enemies but no meaningful attempt to
differentiate the gameplay mind you that
shooting is typically top-notch pulse
rifles shoot their rhythmic garages with
great power and charging up a fusion
rifle and releasing its payload is akin
to holding your breath and then
expelling it in one rewarding sigh the
game's best compaq feature however might
be its melee attack regardless of which
of the game's three all to similar
classes you choose destiny nails its
feel that special difficult to define
something comprised of fluid controls
excellent collision detection and
awesome technology that
every action silky and responsive you
can leap and glide through the air a
mechanic that gives destiny a sense of
freedom that matches its open spaces and
helps you escape danger when encounters
get tough the most powerful foes put up
a decent fight using cover to their
advantage protecting themselves with
shields or assailing UN masse if only
you got access to the aliens cool
looking firearms instead of being
confined to the game's excellent but
bog-standard arsenal luckily you gain
access to different types of slow to
replenish grenades and a few super
powers such as the warlocks magical
area-of-effect projectile that takes
even longer to recharge but once again
those excellent basics are betrayed by
slow-paced and redundant tasks that have
you asking yourself hey isn't this the
same Canyon I was heading down five
minutes ago hey didn't I just cross this
hill 10 minutes ago and 20 minutes ago
and an hour ago it's tempting to compare
destiny to full-fledged massively
multiplayer role-playing games but doing
so reveals how much more diverse typical
MMOs really are
by contrast destiny gives its plan
missions context so thin that it may
have been better off without them it
certainly tries to tell a story a story
that seems like it might come into its
own about halfway through when you meet
two of Destiny's few non Dinklage
characters alas destiny wastes the
opportunity to develop a mystery worth
caring about
and reverts to more fetch quests
followed by a manipulative ending that
reminds you that the game's soundtrack
does far more work in establishing this
worlds tone than the mediocre writing
ever does Dinklage is sleepy not quite
robot not quite human delivery doesn't
help in this regard though to be fair
some of the item descriptions and the
lore heavy stories you can read on
Destiny's official website fill in some
narrative gaps but you'd be hard-pressed
to remember much that happened in
Destiny's story let alone
understand them once you leave it behind
which might take you around 15 hours or
so there's loot of course much of it in
the form of new weapons or weapon
blueprints called engrams which you can
redeem at a hub called the tower which
you share with a dozen plus other
players if you're used to the plethora
of loot you receive while playing games
like Borderlands or Diablo 3 however
make sure to prepare for destinies
slower pace for doling out rewards it's
perhaps befitting that meaningful new
stuff doesn't come that frequently given
how destiny on the whole feels like a
standard-sized experience stretched
entirely too thin other aspects of
destiny feel less stretched into
oblivion than they do wholly underdone
the presence of other players not your
group for example is more
window-dressing than vital mechanic
given how few appear in your travels and
how very rare public combat events are
that bring people together once you
reach level 20 you might enjoy the
upcoming rate event though it's not yet
available as at the time of this review
it's not yet certain however that
repeating a raid will be any more fun
than repeating strikes and story
missions which along with competitive
multiplayer are the only things you
truly do once you finish Destiny's
undercooked story if you enjoy grinding
for gear that's a good thing the promise
of wearing better stuff is the sole
purpose to forging ahead the crucible
where Destiny's competitive multiplayer
lurks is quite competent developer
Bungie shows off its mastery of level
design with maps of various sizes that
get used across four different modes
six-member deathmatch finds its legs on
maps that recall the winding corridors
and central combat arenas of Unreal
Tournament and team deathmatch functions
just fine control mode is the most
enjoyable however allowing both lone
wolves and focus teams to contribute
sometimes in the cockpit of one of the
two ground vehicles available there are
some issues here such as the way the
auto targeting can cause one opponent to
grab your targeting reticle when you're
trying to fire at a different target
however competitive play proves itself a
worthy way of leveling up and earning
access to items you wouldn't otherwise
be able to
please allow me to summarize destiny by
telling you what it was like to complete
the story once the final utterly
hackneyed scene finished my to fire team
members and I were rewarded with the
same exact weapon even though all three
of us were playing different classes and
we received a handful of currency and
that was the big narrative finale of a
troubled game that excels in the basics
but is lacking in creativity and heart
it is a clearly expensive game lavishly
produced and devoted to showing off it's
amazing but sterile environments that
look like this world had far better
stories to tell in the past long before
you ever set foot in it the fantastic
gunplay and promise of better loot could
keep you pushing forward the sheer lack
of mission diversity and overall
creativity however make it equally as
likely you'll lead destiny behind for
something with more excitement and more
soul
the way out of your seat